the latest destiny to stream was loaded
with new content so let's break down
everything you need to know there's a
new expansion another season of content
and upcoming ports for PS 5 and Xbox
series X the expansion is called beyond
light and it's taking players to Europa
one of Jupiter's moons it's a cold
frozen place and you'll find the Golden
Age Bray tech facility under its ice
Europa is also home to the rebuilt
fallen Empire run by Aramis the ships
dealer she's the big bad of beyond light
so expect to see her clash with the
Guardians also under Europa's ice is
deep stone crypt which has been dormant
for a long time
it'll be opened up for a new six person
raid and of course there are plenty of
rewards to earn inside with new areas
comes a new damage type
we've got arc solar and void and Beyond
light is adding stasis which deals
darkness type damage Bungie says we'll
learn more about stasis later in the
summer but Titans warlocks and hunters
will all wield it differently from one
another the reveal trailer for beyond
light also picked up a story thread from
way back in Destiny 1 the return of the
EXO stranger last time we saw her was in
the original games vanilla campaign
where she told us she didn't even have
the time to explain why she didn't have
time to explain
yeah thanks beyond light launches on
September 22nd and it's up for pre-order
now you can find more info about
pre-order bonuses and special editions
on GameSpot right now we have more to
talk about because destiny 2 season of
arrivals has just started today when
we're putting out this video
things are kicking off with a pyramid
ship landing on Io a new public event is
available at the landing site you can
also explore a new dungeon called
prophecy and it involves the 9 in some
way it opens up at 5:00 p.m. Pacific 8
p.m. Eastern today June 9th
you'll also find strange messages on the
moon as the season continues destiny 2
does love its crowd-sourced puzzles and
of course there's new gear and rewards
to unlock during season of arrivals
what's more the new Angra focus system
lets you unlock the ability to fine tune
the rewards you receive now maybe you
haven't tried destiny 2 yet may
you're waiting to try it on a new
console good news it's coming to PS 5
and Xbox series X and it'll be free to
play on those consoles too what's more
any content you've purchased on current
gen systems can be transferred via a
free upgrade anything you've bought on
ps4 including beyond light will transfer
to PS 5 and Xbox one purchases will
transfer to series X Bungie will also
offer intergenerational cross play
meaning ps4 and five players can play
together an Xbox one in series X players
can also play together true cross play
is in the works but don't expect it any
time this year so that's a ton of
destiny to news and Bungie says there's
more to come later this year
stay tuned a game spot for all the
latest on the space shooting adventure
you